you can't spread the flu if you don't
have symptoms
that is absolutely false you can't get
the flu shot if you're sick
so i've heard this one a bunch of times
the flu is similar to
cold no the flu can be a killer
i'm robert jacobs and i'm a professor of
pediatrics at mayo clinic
and i'm dr tanya elliott i'm an
allergist immunologist by training
we're here to debunk some flu myths so
myth number one
you can't get the flu shot if you're
sick so i've heard this one a bunch of
times
listen if you have a mild illness like a
cough or a runny nose or a low grade
fever
you are not off the hook now some people
who are recovering from covet 19 will
wonder
should they get the flu shot and yes
they should
as soon as they've recovered from the
acute phase of their
covid19 infection and are no longer
contagious
myth two the flu vaccine gives you the
flu
the flu vaccine doesn't contain anything
that could give you
the flu infection we're not seeing any
more rates of illnesses
after the flu vaccine than we would if
we were giving a placebo
injection of salt water and listen if
you have a couple of aches or pains or
you feel unwell
consider this being a sign that your
immune system is working
myth number three it's too late to get
the flu shot
it is not too late to get the flu shot
as long as the flu virus is circulating
and that season is from october all the
way through may
getting the flu shot is beneficial yes
you should get it as soon as it's
available
but that doesn't excuse you if somehow
you didn't get it
in october and november you can't get
the flu
after you've had the flu shot i wish
we had a flu vaccine that was a hundred
percent effective
we don't but it's not zero percent
effective
either it does work most years about
half the time
and it turns out in preventing half the
cases
we can actually prevent outbreaks and
spreads it is our best
chance and the majority of time you will
be protected against getting the flu
and this year with covet 19 we have to
do everything we can
to prevent every single case a couple of
reasons why you may still
get the flu one you may have been
exposed to the virus
right before you got the vaccine so the
vaccine didn't have time to kick in
two you might be exposed to other
strains of the flu that weren't in the
vaccine
three your immune system may not have
mounted a strong enough response to the
vaccine
or four you have some other virus and
it's not actually the flu
myth five the flu vaccine is effective
for
a year well it's typically affected for
the entire flu
season which is about six months but
then the immunity
starts to wane and also the types of
viruses or the strains of viruses that
cause infections
could mutate the flu vaccine is a
hundred percent effective
i wish it was true i wish it was it's
not it's about 50
effective we don't have a crystal ball
so the way it works is scientists from
around the world come together every
year and make their best guess
at which strains of the flu virus
because there are a bunch of them
should be included in the flu vaccine
based on which are the most dangerous or
which are the most prevalent meaning
which are the ones that are circulating
so
we don't get it right a hundred percent
of the time but
the truth is this is the best guess and
it's based on predictive analytics and
based on science and based on history
so it's pretty darn good studies
recently in the past years
have shown while it's not a hundred
percent effective
those who get sick with the flu despite
getting the flu vaccine
have a milder course than those who
didn't get the flu vaccine
myth seven you shouldn't get the flu
shot while pregnant
i just had a baby you should absolutely
get the flu shot while you're pregnant
the last thing you would want is to get
sick with an
illness that could land you in the
hospital while you're pregnant
we now recognize pregnancy as being one
of the big risk factors for getting a
bad
case of the flu and it does give
the baby in the first six months of life
some protection against the flu
which otherwise we can't solve because
our flu vaccines don't work in babies
under six months of age
it protects you and the baby too myth
eight
healthy people don't need a flu shot i
hear this
so many times why should they get the
flu vaccine
many times people get the flu and don't
recognize it's the flu
it's also a great way to protect your
children your loved ones your relatives
and your neighbors
if i can prevent myself from getting
something and stay healthy
why wouldn't i do that it's so important
that even if you
may have a mild case of the flu it
doesn't mean that you may not spread it
to family members and loved ones so do
everyone a favor absolutely
and get the flu shot myth nine
antibiotics will treat a flu infection
okay so i hear this all the time oh all
i need is a zpac and i'm going to be
better
i wish that people would understand
antibiotics actually have
very little role in treating most of the
colds coughs and illnesses that we get
during the year
antibiotics treat bacterial infections
the flu
is a virus antibiotics don't work
against viruses myth 10 the flu is
similar to cold
no the flu can be a killer we don't have
people who
die of the common cold every year we
have in the united states
tens of thousands of people end up in
the critical care unit
tens of thousands who die from the flu
we don't have that with the common cold
you know the only thing that's similar
is that
the flu is a virus and a cold is caused
by viruses
and some of the symptoms can be
overlapping where you can have a fever
or a cough or runny nose or sore throat
but it ends there consider the flu
about a hundred even a thousand times
worse than a cold
myth 11 you can't get the flu more than
once a year
there is a chance that you can get the
flu more than once a year
we right now vaccinate against four
strains of the flu
with our vaccines so we do a pretty good
job with the vaccine
in preventing those four strains but
that means there's
four strains circulating every year that
means you could have four different
outbreaks in a
in a single individual there's a chance
you could be infected with a different
strain of the flu
and there's also a chance that maybe
your immune system
didn't melt a strong enough response
to the flu vaccine in the first place
myth 12 you can't spread the flu if you
don't have symptoms
that is absolutely false we've heard
this over and over again with cobit 19
right that you can be an asymptomatic
carrier you may not even know that you
have the virus and you could still be
spreading it
very similar story with the flu in fact
you can be infectious the day before
you develop symptoms in the first place
and even for days
after you could still be shedding the
virus
myth 13 you don't need a flu shot
every year so remember the flu vaccine
is good for about
six months or so so it covers you for
the flu season
and remember that each year we
may be changing the types of strains
that we put into the flu vaccine that
you would be protected against so
that's why it's really important to get
the flu vaccine every year
people who are allergic to eggs
shouldn't get the flu shot so
i'm an hour just in clinical
immunologists i hear this
all of the time if you have an egg
allergy
you can still get the flu shot there are
some flu vaccines that are made with
a minuscule and i mean minuscule be like
less than trace amount
of egg protein but the truth is the
protein that's present in the vaccine
is not the same protein that egg
allergic people
react to we actually now know through
hundreds and hundreds of patients with
serious anaphylactic reactions of eggs
that they have no more risk of having an
allergic or anaphylactic reaction
than people without them egg allergies
used to be thought to be a problem
but science has shown it's not an issue
if you have a severe severe egg allergy
anaphylactic shock and you're really
concerned
the recommendation is get the flu shot
in the doctor's office
and wait for 30 minutes just to be sure
the other thing i'll note is that they
do make egg free
flu vaccines and so again if you're
super nervous or concerned
there is that alternative available for
you as well
myth 15 taking vitamin c will prevent
the flu
that's not true in fact we don't have
nutrients that you can put add as
supplements or foods that you can eat
that will protect you against the flu
what will protect you against the flu
the vaccine
hand washing with soap and water
avoiding people with
cough and sneeze obviously if you do
have the flu
you should take steps to cover your
cough and avoid exposing others
absolutely maybe on the margin vitamin c
might help your immune system a little
bit and even that science is a little
sketchy
but absolutely it will not prevent you
from getting the flu nor will any other
concoction of
immune boosting agents